e
okayy good morning to members of the
public and to committee members um due
to the fact we have concurring things
going on between here and other
committees uh within the the house and
the Senate here I have to be out of here
in four minutes to testify in a bill
upstairs in Commerce uh our Municipal
and um what we're going to do is we're
going to take a break and not have any
executive action taking place till
11:00 and so we'll be caucusing probably
around quarter of 11 to 11 o'clock and
then coming back we do have some
amendments which we are looking at for
the first time I have not yet read them
and so that's what we have to do between
now and and
11:00 and so with that um we'll just
take a break and we'll come back at 11
to take action on the those remaining
bills any questions
yes there's still one you are we still
lacking one asked for but we don't
am use your red
yeah yeah thank you so I didn't have any
when I first got here this morning so I
sent I printed out the emails I sent OS
that have the Amendments I requested so
you have that uh since then I have
received two out of the three amendments
from OS uh you have those as well
although one printed incorrectly
apologies for that um we're waiting on
the third which is the AED related uh
Amendment um I hope to have that very
shortly okay as soon as that arrives
upstairs we might want to contact them
and say we're waiting on that uh we need
to get it to both caucuses as soon as we
can so I'm going to head down upstairs
right now to third floor uh any other
questions thank you so we're taking a
hour
e
but it wasn't due to any hour try good
morning to everybody
again uh we still have about 29 minutes
left in
morning and so we're going to try to
start with the exing right here and
hopefully get four bills done before we
have
lunch so uh the first bill which we have
on the docket is Senate Bill 375
375 relative to biological sex and
student
Athletics and I'm going to hand the
gavel off to the vice chair
representative pel and she's going to
take over on this particular
Bill going to open the exec Ive session
on House Bill 375 and I call on chairman
lad for the motion yes I'd like to make
the motion of inum study on Senate Bill
375 I'll second
that okay any comments from um the maker
of the motion do you have all that down
okay uh yes uh the we have already
passed previously a bill that deals with
Athletics um both in the second in the
secondary levels this bill also sends it
to the to the college Collegiate level
which we uh did not uh support uh in
when we passed our initial bill and also
there are other components of this which
uh uh have some issue I'm going to let
others speak to that uh so that's all I
have to say on this
one representative luno uh thank you
very much Madam chair um yeah we think
375 doesn't have any place doesn't have
any business in um in New Hampshire and
um and discri discriminates um not only
against a a protected um uh
classification but uh but but but really
um um you know also
violates not only you know aspects of
Title 9 uh but fair play and frankly
what we heard from almost 40 people
yesterday that hey these kids just want
to play and be part of the team so thank
you
okay any other comments from the rest of
the committee Bel and yes representative
Belcher thank you madam chair I'll just
speak quickly because I I will be
supporting the is motion uh my logic is
slightly different I don't mind the idea
of telling colleges and universities
what we need to be doing on this but my
hangup here is that in this bill there
is an exception that allows um young
women to participate on boys teams um I
believe that's somewhat inconsistent
with the uh the goal of preventing
injury despite the fact that the women
are making the decision to we're talking
about young girls who were not adults
who do not have a full measure of agency
I don't think that's a decision they
should be making and I also think boy
Sports deserve to be protected because I
think any well brought up young man who
is conscientious probably would not go
100% against a female as I probably
would not have um and I think they
deserve that opportunity as well thank
you you any other
comments not seeing none will the clerk
please call the
role Vice chairman
Pell yes Representative leus no
representative elure yes representative
dry yes representative McDonnell yes
representative Noble
yes representative AAR yes
representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
luno
yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Corgan yes representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
Kaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes chairman lad
n ask if there's any problem with
consent um 191 any problems with consent
that's good
um do we have this one back
yes okay the next bill which we're going
to have is uh Senate Bill
uh relative to emergency action plans
for sports related
injuries and on this I'm going to hand
the gavel off
perinel open the executive session on
Senate Bill 379 relative to emergency
action plans for sports related injuries
and I call on chairman lad to make the
motion uh yes I will make the motion of
OTP on 37 79 relative to emergency
action plans for sports related injuries
I'll second
second any um comments from the maker of
the
motion uh yes I do have comments I think
the the issue of putting AED units in uh
our Public Schools is very very
important and I support this 110%
uh external defibrillators are are
needed um uh what we want to do though
is we we have to be careful how we walk
around this in terms of funded vers
unfunded mandates uh however uh having
been involved with Athletics and sports
my entire life and my family definitely
all of them are in either division one
or division three Athletics I have seen
injuries on the field where this would
have been a needed item and not just for
those that are athletes though but it's
also important that we have it there
available for people that are my age
that are going to be 79 here in another
few months and um cardiac issues are
very common amongst grandparents and
parents and young children even so I
think that this is a a a a safety issue
a health issue and it's just playing
good policy so I do support the issue of
AED uh units in schools I'm a little
concerned though uh I don't want to walk
too much on the turf of mandating
something that's unfunded at this time
so but I do like this bill as it's
written I think that tries to scoot
around that issue so with that Madam
chair I'm you know please to ask for
OTP thank you is there another motion to
be
made representative leus yeah
go ahead and and but then yes I will
want to put in another motion on the
second comment I was just going to add
that was great representative uh Mr
chair um bottomline saving lives I think
with having Piper Moran here as a living
example of why it's important and uh at
all all all age levels um yeah so I'm
all
in yes I call on representative leus for
another motion yes I would like to move
um to amend the
with Amendment
15968 and the reason is because as we
got into the discussion on this we were
concerned not so much
um initially we weren't concerned about
it being an unfunded mandate because it
says if the school but the problem comes
in it's a safety issue the problem comes
in if the school has one AED
and it's supposed to be within 3
minutes the sports team is going to take
the AED from its recognized place where
it is in the school where the emergency
Personnel know where it is where
everybody else in the school knows what
it is and have to take it out to the
field now if there's an emergency in the
school leus excuse me we need a second
before you're going to be
a there you
go um I call in representative Hall were
you second this amendment not the
amendment not the amendment okay okay so
the issue is then if there's an
emergency in the school or someplace
else like at a different field whatever
people are going to go where they know
the AED is but it's not going to be
there and so the way to remedy that and
this is where we got into unfunded
mandate would be to provide multiple
aeds so that they could be where they
belonged and we came up with an
amendment to provide M to pay for the
state to pay for but it's not a budget
year and we were told we couldn't do
that and if we just mandated that they
did it that was an unfunded mandate and
so what we decided was to take the
parts that were absolutely essential and
didn't add other safety issues passed
them this year and put in the proper
Bill next year that takes care of those
and next year is a budget year and it
doesn't cost that much and if the state
just paid for aeds for all this you know
to
each each um District but I also noticed
that one kid leaving for an EFA that
District gets enough money
extra have following it to pay for all
the aeds but just to give an idea of how
little that is so the state could just
pay for them but we can't put that in
this year next year's a budget year put
that in next year put the parts in that
don't cause additional harm additional
safety issues put those in because for
instance making sure it's in a well
marked and safe place so everybody knows
where it is and it's not locked in an
office when the nurse goes home because
a lot of them are in nurses offices and
they go home and the sports teams are
still there and now nobody can get at it
so those we felt were critical enough to
make sure they stayed and to take the 3
minutes out until we can make sure
there's a way that it is 3 minutes away
from every Sports field some of which
are a good 15 or more
minutes you have big schools have sports
teams all over the place there's no way
you can satisfy this the way it's
written so that was the point of
the is try to get as much safety in
without making things unsafe that's it
thank you any further discussion
representative
Damon thank you um why does the
amendment REM remove the requirement for
an individual trained in CPR to be at
sports
activities um it doesn't say be at them
it says supervise and when I tried to
figure out what that meant supervise
organized sports
activities um I didn't get any kind of
reasonable answer is that a person who
supervises all of them is a person who
attends each
one I don't know they didn't they didn't
have then they were talking about
supervisor as in one sports person who
ran around with an AED between all the
things schools don't necessarily have
that especially small schools and it's a
good idea for schools to certify as many
people as possible but we don't have to
make it but this way of writing it in
the law didn't make it clear or make
sense personally I think a whole lot of
people at the school should be certified
in CPR and I think every sports team
should have at least one person in
attendance doesn't have to be
supervising just in attendance but
that's like I said that's part of the
proper bill that needs to be written to
get that right thank you very much
representative dry thank you I think I
can answer your question there's a
reason that aeds can be left in lobbies
of hotels and supermarkets it's because
you turn it on and you do what it says
it's meant to be easy to use 911 can
talk anyone through uh use of an AED and
CPR um this bill also the the statute
already has a school identifying the
Personnel trained in the use of the aeds
so that's already that's already there
who could be done but I'm going to just
say that there's a move across the state
to make sure that staff and even
students who are of appropriate age like
about e8th grade or so are trained in
our area everybody the staff of all the
schools and um all the eighth graders
know how to use an AED and do CPR so I
think that the the general public is out
there it's enough and it's General
enough and easy enough to use that this
is okay um and the school has already
got a list of who's personally trained
if they feel like they need somebody
they've got a list to draw
from thank you um representative
Heath thank you madam chair just a quick
question this does not in any way alter
the need for the plan am I
correct the in in the bill there is a
plan for how to carry every no nothing
has changed okay thank
you representative belch thank you madam
chair I just want to offer a real quick
summary of where we're at here uh this
bill was brought to us from the Senate
um we're generally very supportive of
the concept the trouble is the bill was
not thoroughly fleshed out when it comes
to the nuances and risks that are
associated with this as well as the
financial component of it this would
either there was two ways to look at
this either we create an unfunded
mandate which would be unconstitutional
or we properly fund this trouble is we
don't have enough time to do that right
now because our deadline is here so we
want to do what we can in this that is
actually not creating any constitutional
problems and return to flesh out the
rest of this as it should be to actually
do something next year with this thank
you
thank you any further discussion and
seeing none Madam clerk will you please
15968 Vice chair
peternell yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
represent representative AAR yes
representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
luno
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner no representative
Horgan no representative wock yes
representative Hall no representative
Bon
yes representative
cascaden yes representative
Damon no representative Heath
yes chairman lad
yes 168 for n okay make a
motion you call on chairman lad to make
a motion uh yes I'd like to move uh 379
1596 I'll second that oh who was the
for that that motion is seconded by
representative Hall any further
discussion yeah I just make a quick note
that I think as was asked by represent
Damon training is absolutely NE
necessary and uh that's that's addressed
in the bill but I also think what
representative dry said is absolutely
correct you can turn the button on and
then you got it talking to you that's
probably more pertinent than uh the
other but um I the the the aeds we need
these and this bill is a good bill for
everyone so I would recommend that we we
support this as much as we can thank
you any further discussion not seeing
any Madam clerk will please call the
role CH Pell yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative a yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Luna yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Horgan yes representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes chairman lad
yes 280 n thank you any objections to
consent not seeing
I
no we you're not going
to
ient because I didn't think you would
let me say anything anyways but somebody
said don't you want to write an opposing
our it has to be mad I'll talk to you
27 Senate Bill 217 this is establishing
a rule and underserved Area Educator
incentive program for hired ucation and
making an appropriation
therefore and I'd like to recognize uh
motion thank you chairman NAD I move
ought to pass on uh
217 I'll second that okay we have a
motion on on the floor excuse me uh of
for seven Senate Bill 2117 is a to pass
made by representative peternell and
second by representative luno
discussion did we have the new Amendment
back on this yet we were waiting on an
amendment on that do we have the new one
back yet we don't have that nothing
[Laughter]
it okay what we can do is we can recess
take not you know and and go on to the
and
yeah
is a bill that deals relative mandatory
Disclosure by School District employees
to parents and I uh recognize
representative vure for a motion
please thank you Mr chair I would move
on to pass second so we have a motion on
the table made by representative Belcher
as ought to pass and second by
representative McDonald further
discussion from the maker of the motion
thank you Mr chair uh if I may I would
89h everyone should have a copy and I'll
amendment
okay you said 1593
H 158 9h
89 it's a short one okay got it okay we
have a motion on the table made by
represent Bel second by represent
McDonald uh and uh the motion is to uh
OTP the amendment 1589 representative
Bel want to speak to your yes thank you
Mr chair um in the in the original bill
I had I had one concern of some
magnitude when it came to the uh
standard that was being used as far as
the uh the good faith Judgment of a
credential person because that is a
atypical um judicial standard
for any sort of adjudication um I don't
know how that would be adjudicated it
would be very complicated I imagine so I
I would insert instead the very common
uh judicial standard of the reasonable
person standard uh just a very minor
change that I think brings this more in
line with
precedent thank you further discussion
from the second no further discussion
from the floor or from the committee
not seeing
clerk oh
did oh represent Luna yeah thanks thanks
very much um you know honestly there's
there's nothing any Amendment uh
certainly not this amendment can do to
um so it does it it certainly doesn't
change my my position on on the bill
thank you any further discussion Madam
clerk would you please call the RO on
the
amendment 1589 H go ahead Vice chair p
no yes representative leus yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
AAR yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes Representative
luno no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative horon no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no representative
Heath no chairman lad yes 10 y 10 days
so the motion
fails and we're back to the main motion
of ought to
pass any further discussion on the main
motion that I ought to pass on 34 1
represent belshire thank you Mr chair we
heard all about this yesterday so I'll
be very brief uh simple concept of the
bill would require um those Educators to
answer you know truthfully and honestly
to inquiries by parents and Guardians
regarding their children um I will
address one objection that was raised
the idea that truthful and honesty is uh
is a two- weighty standard that would
require them to say things that they may
not know so they have to take notes
constantly about what each child is
doing absolutely not absolutely not all
it would require is the truth and
honesty to the best of their knowledge
there is no new standard being
introduced in this bill that would
require constant observation and
notetaking it's just to the best of your
knowledge answer answer truthfully and
honesty about about about a child to
their parent thank you further
discussion represent McDonald thank you
Mr
chair as stated by the pre Prime sponsor
of the bill yesterday this legislation
only addresses education process and it
as amended ensures student safety
moreover the bill recognizes the role of
Educators as mandatory reporters and the
fundamental rights of parents to guide
the upbringing of their minor children
in addition because of the concerns that
were addressed yesterday I'd like to
underscore that nothing within this bill
even mentions any particular Community
never mind targets any particular
community and for that reason I believe
there's been a substantial
misunderstanding during yesterday's disc
discussion however with respect to New
Hampshire's lgbtq plus students this
bill ensures that more adults are aware
so they can be compassionate with
much-needed love and support and New
Hampshire is fortunate to be home to
both excellent teachers and excellent
parents and a number of individuals from
both groups were present yesterday and
it's Paramount that members of both
groups collaborate to ensure that the
best possible opportunities for all
students including transgender students
and finally having difficult discussions
Fosters greater understanding which can
only occur with a commitment to honesty
and to integrity and for these reasons I
support the Bill thank you thank you
very much is there any further
discussion yes representative
luno so thank you very much Mr chair so
yesterday um during the hearing and if
I've got my um if I if I took accurate
notes and got my count correct
um only people including the prime
sponsor spoke in support of the bill 34
speak people spoke opposed to the bill
and um and of the people that spoke for
um they did not
identify
um as well actually the prime sponsor
did identify um himself as a um as a
parent um the others one other
um but of the 34 that spoke in
opposition um many identified as parents
many identified as
as actually some identified as parents
of of um of trans athletes some
identified as athletes that play on the
same sports teams as trans athletes some
identified as experts um whether or not
they were the I mean some identified as
experts being the the the the head of of
New Hampshire's U um Association of
Social Workers
ACLU um
teachers
groups and it and it just it it it
baffles me that that this
committee can't seem to bring itself to
to listen to and respond to the
overwhelming amount of testimony
from parents from teachers from experts
from students from trans kids from trans
athletes and from from um from
cisgendered athletes when it comes to
looking at um at at this at this uh bill
here and you know at the at the end of
the day what what what keeps coming back
to me is something that I read in a um
in know in a report
um in in the in the conquered local
newspaper um with respect to a related
Bill not 341 but uh but a related Bill
and um and it was by a mom who writes
quote it doesn't matter what anybody
says it doesn't matter what the
statistics say or what the professionals
say end quote they have the quote begins
again they have their opinion and they
aren't going to change it no matter what
anybody says and I don't think that's
what what we're I don't think that's
what our voters put here put us here for
I think our I think Granite Staters
hardworking Granite Staters put us here
to listen to
them and we're not doing that and I hope
as we do move towards a vote on this
that people will consider you know
nobody's got a mandate on this issue
this isn't an ideological mandate um but
we pretty we heard clearly from our
friends from our neighbors from Granite
Staters from all over the state who
traveled down here and spent a long day
with us yesterday um and I just hope U
members of the committee will recognize
that and um and be responsible to uh to
the people that uh will be holding all
of us accountable um come the primary
and come November thank you further
discussion represent
cordello thank you Mr
chair I don't care if a hundred people
came in yesterday opposed this bill and
one supported it it basically says you
shall not
lie and therefore that is why it should
be
supported represent
chair I have spent over 30 years in
public education as a teacher and
administrator as a coach in all those
times in leadership my one piece to
every teacher came in the door is
students first students first
and this bill puts students second thank
you representative
Hall thank you you shall not lie I just
heard I was an educator for 40 years
thousands parent conferences IEP
meetings with parents with other
teachers not once can I say that I heard
lies at those meetings not once in this
job in my last three years I've heard
lies
so let's be clear teachers this whole
thing that teachers are lying all the
time is ridiculous it's an insulting
leus I
taught I was also a girl scout leader
for 15
years which meant I had very close
contact with a lot of girls and I made
it very clear to the girls that yeah we
were going to be talking about a lot of
sensitive issues especially as they were
getting older once they started Cadets
we sat down and really had a
conversation and we made it clear to
them that we would not lie to their
parents and if they told us things that
we felt were very harmful to them we
would tell the parents you know
what those girls confided all kinds of
information to us they talked to us
about all kinds of things they didn't
feel comfortable talking to their
parents St out they called me mom and
all the the parents were fine with that
cuz they were happy to have that one
trusted adult that was me for a lot of
years so much so that when a daughter
was definitely clearly going through
something that she didn't feel
comfortable talking to her mom her mom
called me and said can you go camping
with my daughter and a friend up at my
dad's hunting lodge so my daughter can
talk to you
and we had and it was very personal
stuff she was going with and the thing
is they trusted me to do that because
they knew I would not lie to them and
the kids knew what the boundaries were
and knew that I would not lie and yet
they still felt very comfortable talking
to me and I don't think we should be
telling teachers that they're to lie to
students I think that breaks the trust
from both I mean lies to parents which
at least one school district actually
has on its
website and um I think it's very harmful
and I think it's also teaching children
that lying is okay because if oh yeah
I'm going to tell the truth except with
for this then this it's okay to lie in
this case but not in that case I was
very clear I was not going to lie and I
think it was very important and I think
I was able to have those conversations
with those kids that otherwise they
would not have been able to have an
adult to talk to If I had
not firmly stood by I will not lie and
if there is something that I think is
really harmful to you I will pass it on
to your parents further discussion
representative
Damon thank you Mr
chair this is clearly a very emotional
and concerning proposed piece of
legislation no matter which perspective
I am so impressed by the
Courage The
Voice the experience of the people who
have testified both in person and I have
had a lot of constituent messages and
conversations there are about
90% in opposition to the bill and 10% in
favor and all of those people equally
believe believe that they are choosing
the right thing for
children I will be voting to oppose this
bill because I think that when you
violate or persecute one group it is
just a beginning of what follows from
there and I will Echo the wonderful man
who spoke yesterday on both this bill
and 375 one of the many wonderful
speakers I'm sorry I can't quote his
name
accurately he said he was 76 years old
and he had been homophobic until his
daughter came out to him when he was
44 and I spoke with him during the break
to learn a little more about his
experience and he said his whole family
knew that his daughter was gay and
protected her and him from knowing
because they felt his reaction would be
harmful to her and eventually she got to
the place where she said to him dad I
want you to love me for who I am not for
who you think I am and he spent several
years in therapy and now he is an
advocate for the rights of all people
and he was also the gentleman who at the
end of his remarks said and I am a
Vietnam veteran and I fought for
everyone's freedoms that's what we need
to do in opposing this bill this is for
everyone's
freedoms further discussion from
committee members representative Cornell
and then representative
thank you um I just think this is a very
vague Bill and will be difficult to
enforce in fact if anything is you know
determined um that when a parent writes
to a credentialed not a non-credentialed
employee but just credentialed so um
what would determine complete and honest
and so I went back and I I read the
testimony from the Senate hearing and
Diana Fenton from the Department of
Education said that the complete and
honest standard was unclear seemed
subjective and would be difficult to
she the termination was beyond the
purview um it would fall outside the
State Board of
Education it's just I don't know if you
have to report something to dcyf rather
than answer the parent but you have to
answer the parent within 10 days but it
sometimes takes DCF longer than 10 days
to investigate something plus they don't
investigate if it's only risk they only
investigate if it's something that's
actually happened so I think this is
just something that's just going to
cause a lot of problems just even trying
to figure out what you're supposed to do
so I I am not in favor of this thank you
representative Bon thank you Mr chair um
I will be voting against this one and um
it goes contrary to a program that we
have in the Department of Education and
we've talked about that it's called one
trusted adult and we should be
encouraging students um especially when
they are experiencing some kind of event
in their life and they might not feel
comfortable talking to their parents
about it for whatever reason according
to the one trusted adult program it says
to the children what you say in here
stays in here unless someone is hurting
you you want to hurt someone you want to
hurt yourself or you give permission to
share with another trusted adult so I
don't understand how you can have this
program and support this legislation
thank you thank you representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair and I'll just
respond to some of some of the
criticisms I've heard because I've heard
so far that
it's not happening and I've also heard
that it's good that it's happening and I
I just don't think continuing to
Gaslight the public on this issue is
going to keep working for people we know
that it's happening this didn't come out
of thin air I can cite one specific
policy that proliferated in New
jbab that explicitly requires either
dishonesty or Silence of Educators when
parents asked them about certain things
about their own children this was in my
own School District until it was very
recently repealed
thankfully um so this this didn't come
out of thin air it's a real phenomena
it's too bad that we have to have this
conversation and put this kind of thing
in law now but I never would have
thought we would had to but we do we
have to protect uh the the lawful right
of parents to direct the upbringing of
their children and as far as this idea
that there is some sort of
confidentiality enshrined in law between
a child a teacher that's utter nonsense
utterly nonsense even when it comes to
the health care providers of minors
there is not a confidentiality when
parents are involved because they're the
parents Children Are Not Mere creatures
of the state children belong to their
families their parents there is not a
presumption of guilt on these parents
until proven otherwise there is a
presumption of innocence they are
innocent unless we can prove that they
have committed a crime only then can
they be stripped of their parental
rights thank you thank you very much is
there any for yes representative Tanner
thank you um I'd just like to say ditto
to uh what a lot of my colleagues have
have said today particularly that um
this is insulting to teachers um and
that there is the um policy that uh
representative belter mentioned uh he
had a little difficulty finding it uh
when I asked him about it because it has
been rescinded at this particular time
it's no longer in effect um um I would
say that in my 35 years of teaching and
coaching and I think um several people
that I heard on Zoom yesterday talk
about their experiences that students
just and also representative leus that
students do come to you and ask for you
know as a way to talk things out a way
to to um deal with some issues they find
very difficult and as you talk to them
um you're talking to them about you know
speaking to their parents which a lot of
people uh talked about yesterday too
that that it was the initial contact and
that um they talked the the student
through it um silence sometimes is the
best thing to say like if someone says
the this make me look fat um most guys
will say silence is the is the better
discretionary thing to to uh do and I
think that it points out that nothing in
life is black and white like this law
makes it um there's a lot of discretion
in how you handle different things a lot
of discretion in how um you approach
things with with parents with other
students with um uh anybody who is
coming to you and revealing something
that you know they would not like
everybody else in the world to know
about so um I think that this Bill uh
has a lot more bad unintended or
intended consequences to it as far as
how it's going to affect teacher student
relationships credential teachers only
and um it's going to you know it it's it
one size doesn't fit all you just don't
do yes or no lie or you're not lying um
you know it the it just fails to look at
the innuendos of human
interaction social interaction and
common decency so in those Reasons I'm
not going to be voting for this Bill
thank you is there any further
discussion from the committee represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to clarify that the policy that
representative belter brought up
jbab is a withdrawn sample transgender
policy um it was drawn withdrawn two
years ago because of misinterpretation
the policy was
intended to say that schools could not
tell uh a student status to other
parents not that student's parents but
that they could not tell it to other
parents we live in small communities
where travels the policy was determined
to be um confusing or or easily
misinterpreted it was withdrawn it
doesn't exist represent dry hey except
that I'm looking at mine from planfield
school right now that and the sign up to
change your name and your gender is
still on here and it just says you will
not uh disclose it to anyone including
parents unless you have the permission
of the person it
is further discussion from the committee
we have a motional floor made by
represent beler second by represent
McDonald the motion is OTP on SB 341
Madam clerk would you please call the
role VI chair
Pell yes representative leus yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
AAR yes representative Coro yes
representative Terry yes Representative
luno no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Horgan no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
Balon no Representative cascaden no no
representative Damon no representative
Heath no chairman lad yes 10 y 10
motion I move itl and second by
representative Tanner so we have a
motion on the floor itl made by
representative Damon and second by
representative
Tanner any further
discussion I think we all know what we
think okay from the second
same from the
committee Madam clerk when you're ready
we're ready the motion is itl on SBA 341
made by represent Damon second by
representa
Tanner Vice chair Pell no Representative
leus no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative AAR no Representative
corello no representative Terry no
representative Luna yes yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
organ
yes yes on the yes on the itl sorry okay
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Heath yes chairman lad no 10 years 10
okay represent am y can write the one
report and I'm sure represent belshire
the other
report okay we're still waiting
on Senate Bill 217 has an amendment Jen
yet
okay so we're we're GNA take a break
right now and try to hunt this thing
down because that's the last bill we
have
well we all have the the original
version of this amendment 1593 and it's
just word yeah we want to just talk
about that so that we can sure we we we
it okay 1593 is the bill which we're
looking at
folks 2 excuse 217 excuse me 217
159 1593 is the old amendment I should
misspoke on that uh which we're trying
to get changed if you're looking at 1593
H right now it' be down on line
11 where there are several words which
are taken out where it says employed as
an instructional or pupil and uh I
scratched mine out pretty I did that
service employe pupil Service employee
so or pupil service has been scratched
out and it simply says employed as an
instructional employee anybody that's in
there working with kids is in
instructing so it doesn't say anything
about certified so it be instructional
employee credential is on the line 10
already so that's that's the the minor
it represent Damon so what is the
meaning of a people's Service employee I
why it would it would have to be a
credentialed
individual as on the line above you do
have certain Paras that have
credentials and so that it that
individual would also come up but they
also are inst structional
nature does it what about like uh
language Pathologists or um School
psychologists or guidance counselors or
I I consider them all part of
instruction you know they I used to have
a psychologist in school and that
psychologist had kids in his office for
teaching them and working with them uh
and and and the same thing with the
physical therapists or the speech
pathologists often times well that is
instruction uh they're in there meshing
up often times speech therapist is using
the same material that the teacher in
the classroom may use to help with
certain sounds
articulation they are credential they
are credential employees
in fact to get certification as a speech
pathologist you have to have your
Masters plus your C's which is a very
difficult Ash a test but are I mean
usually when we've been using the word
credentialed we've been uh referencing
the Department of Education
credentialing uh for
instruction and so I'm wondering if if
we're eliminating a lot of people by
know Bel I I don't believe we are but
represent beler thank you Mr chair I
just want to let you know I have
received the amendment I've just
forwarded it the HCS for printing uh we
should have it momentarily I'll go get
it um but just a comment on what yep it
is
16028 y um so what this does obviously
just take a quick look it we've we've
changed the program to a grant program
we want to make it available to all
teachers who might be able to receive
this based on retention including those
who may not have outstanding student
loans and uh we wanted to really make
clear that this program is is Ed is
aimed at Educators credential Educators
who were there teaching students uh and
I think anyone that we would want to
actually do that with to retain them the
people we have a shortage of would
reasonably fall under the instructional
employee
um
phraseology uh I I don't think it
actually hurts anything to remove people
Service
employee so is your intent is your
intent to cover people who are um doing
like Speech Pathology and physical
therapy and even if it's
not even if they're not having
difficulty retaining people it just
because I mean this seems to be focused
on Rural
schools um and it is all credential
teachers but I'm just I'm I'm wondering
if you know because finding some of
these other people are very difficult
but there may be one locally that you
know has been there forever um or is
moving to a new district and and is
available but not necessarily in a
shortage area so what's your intent
thank you for the question so my intent
in my reading of this would say that if
you are a a credential person involved
in educating which I I believe that
would qualify uh so long as you meet all
the other requirements then then yes
that would that would be an acceptable
use of this however bear in mind that
things that I did not amend that are s
same from the original part of this bill
include a number of other qualifications
um including I believe something about a
um identifying a a shortage
field um to be a part of this program is
critical educator shortages I believe is
shortages let's have people go to the
chair
please okay so down in section
two the department shall identify
specific schools that are affected by
critical educator shortages using the
follow criteria and it has rural
isolation of the school that's the rural
schools or economic disadvantage of the
school based on eligibility to funds
pursuant to Title One Part A of the
federal Elementary and secondary
Education Act what we're trying to do is
say okay those schools who are having
trouble retaining
teachers instructional staff because
they're moving to other schools that
have more money or that are in nicer
areas or whatever ever that we want to
retain them so we're going to give them
a grant for each year that they stay
they're going to get a certain amount of
money and it's it's a retention Grant
it's to try to solve the issue that we
keep hearing about teachers taking other
jobs because they get paid more or
because of all these other things so
this is to try to
directly
help fulfill those by giving a an award
I don't think that's that was the
question the question was critical
shortage in an area of teaching not a
critical shortage in the area of the
state a shortage of science teachers a
shortage of Math teachers not shortage
in the North
country and I don't think it says a
critical shortage in any one area of of
so so Mr chair just to just to be clear
maybe we misunderstood representative
belcher's um remarks with respect to
critical shortage area but but my
understanding is that the um um that the
amendment 1593 H nor the amendment
62h uh puts any Li any restriction or
any limit ation or qualification on on
on how yeah certification areas for for
teachers am I correct on
that
it's yeah yeah so that that's my
than
e
moving forward on this bill right now
2117 s SP 2117 I Look to representa
amendment thank you Mr chair I would
like to
20246 you're there 16
second okay okay represent luno seconds
the motion the motion now is on the
amendment and that amendment is
1602 for 2117
sb217 made by representative beler and
second by represent luno do you care to
speak to your motion represent belshire
thank you Mr chair I'll keep it brief uh
in summary we had a committee uh looking
at teacher retention come forward with
some recommendations the original bill
was in line with that however what we've
done is we've changed some some
significant things in this while keeping
the spirit of the bill what we've done
is create looking to create a grant
program available to teachers in Rural
and underserved areas critical shortage
areas um in order to help with retention
of teachers who are otherwise leaving
some of these uh more rural districts uh
rather than looking at student loans
we're going to put that money directly
in their pockets I like that because it
lets them decide what they want to do
with it is whatever the best use is and
it makes it available to a larger number
of teachers teach and potentially
because there may be some who don't have
student loans and we don't want to be
discriminatory against them just because
they don't have student loans we want to
make this available to them because they
too are worth retaining thank you
further
discussion any further discussion from
the
committee okay Madam clerk would you
please call the role on the amendment
the amendment being
162 that's amendment to
217 Vice chair P now
yes representative leus yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
AAR yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner uh yes
representative Horan yes representative
W yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes represent
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
representative Heath yes chairman lad
yes okay I'd look to representative Pell
for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass as amended on house Senate Bill
217 I'll second that okay we have a
motion in front of us now the motion is
otpa made by representative Pell and
second by representative luno further
discussion
either not seeing any any committee
members not seeing any Madam clerk would
you please call the role VI Pell yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
AAR yes representative cor yellow yes
representative Terry yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Horgan yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative B
bony yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
Keith yes chairman lad yes 28 a
consent good thank you uh so that
concludes the bills for today um that
leaves for this committee two bills left
in the hopper that's SB 340 and SB
378 we do have a subcommittee working on
378 um that appeared in the calendar we
pardon me it's on the 30th whatever the
day that is okay on the
30th and we have no committee meetings
as a whole
scheduled so uh that will be put in the
calendar when we meet next to take care
of the those remaining two bills other
than that looks like we're pretty much
done everything has come our way this
year and that's a lot of legislation
folks and I think every one of us is
tired so thank you very much and have a
good afternoon and a good lunch we're